you're older yeah we have families but
we're still in the super trailer that we
saw you said something about your
marriage like you were worried about the
fate of your marriage what goes down
what can you tease I mean it so I can't
really talk about it cuz I want everyone
to watch but it's just me being drunk
and dramatic and I just worry so much
about Jionni like getting mad about
things that he would never get mad about
so when I'm drunk I'm like oh my god you
said I look pretty you can't say that
like it's all in my head and I'm crazy
so you'll see a play out I'm gonna does
it involve
Vinny it involves everyone involves all
the boys and they're like relax did you
ever think in a million years that you
guys would all be back together living
together on TV again
I mean we were always hoping for it but
we were like when's the right time like
getting me getting married and having
babies and tightening it was just like
all of our lifes were just so hectic we
were like what is this gonna happen I
think this is our time to come back so
we just did it did you feel guilty at
all or what was that like or were you
just mean living your best life
no there was definitely mom guilt
because you know the second day there we
were at a bar and I heard one of the
trolls song come on it's my daughter's
favorite song Lorenzo's fair song and I
started crying I go oh my god I miss my
kids there was the second day there I
was like relax have fun but then you
know my husband won't call me be like oh
you know Giovanna has the flu getting
mom guilt like oh cool cuz I'm gonna go
to a bar and have fun and my daughter's
sick at home and she needs me
so we kind of struggle with that it's
already greenlit for a season two will
you for sure be back will it be in Miami
again we're definitely doing a season
two but I'm hoping that we're not away
from our families like that again
because I cannot leave my
like that again so I'm down for as long
as it's a different kind of format
[Music]